welcome everybody to the third entry in
nerditzky's opening lab this is a much
requested and long awaited video that
i'm very happy to be making today we are
taking on a monumental task
we will be busting the king's gambit
which is defined by e4 e5 f4 and this is
an opening perhaps the oldest opening in
existence it has been played for right
about half a century
it has not been refuted and it
terrorizes players of all levels
particularly beginners and intermediate
players
now before we delve into any specifics i
want to get one thing out of the way
which is that the king's gambit has not
been refuted there is a narrative that
is spread around sometimes that the
king's gambit has been discredited and
that black is winning that is completely
untrue and the king's gambit remains
perhaps not close to white's best
opening not nearly the same objective
strength as let's say the rue lopez or
the italian but an opening that black
has to know and an opening in which
black doesn't get more than a small
advantage if white plays correctly so it
is absolutely an opening that has to be
studied carefully and that's why i'm
making this video this video will be
about 50 minutes long so i invite you to
set aside some time have a board next to
you and as per usual you'll have to
pause the video frequently and really
engage with the material to get the most
out of it i've tried to be as thorough
as possible we'll go through all of the
sidelines and we'll put particular
emphasis on the moves which tend to have
the most air time in online blitz games
so
uh those of you who watch my youtube
channel diligently know that i uploaded
this video two days ago
and unfortunately there was a glitch
where the board did not update for the
last 20 minutes so i decided to record
it again and hopefully this time it'll
be
even better and hopefully we will be
able to avoid the glitch this time i'm
sorry for that
[Music]
so the king's gambit is kind of the
father of all gambits it's the gambit
that people think of when they hear the
word gambit white sacrifices uh the king
bishop's pawn and the point of this is
to facilitate white's control of the
center now the move d4 is a lot easier
to make
and once white has control of the center
he generally seeks to win this pawn back
with with the bishop
now the immediate d4 in this position uh
has long been known to be a mistake and
we'll start by going over this move
because some people still play it and
the reason it's a mistake is because it
allows a very nasty check on h4 and
because of this f4 pawn white can't play
g3 white has to move his king out into
the open and this is of course no fun
so
it quickly became known that white has
to start with a move knight f3 to
prevent queen h4 and i investigated a
variety of different systems the most
popular move the most commonly
recommended move is g5 immediately
clinging to the pawn i looked at this
for a while and i think from an
objective standpoint it's a very good
line but unfortunately i think it plays
right into white's hands and it requires
a tremendous amount of memorization and
precision which goes against kind of the
philosophy of my opening recommendations
white can play several different systems
d4 there's bishop c4 g4 in castles this
is known as the muzio gambit white
sacrifices the knight on f3 and there is
also the move h4 which immediately seeks
to undermine this pawn chain
now in all of these cases it seems to me
that white is having all of the fun even
if black is better objectively and my
repertoire is geared toward primarily
blitz and rapid players which means that
you won't have a lot of time to remember
you know the only move you have to find
on move 15 to not get checkmated and so
after much research i came to the
conclusion that the most practical and
objectively strong variation
is
a move that is not nearly as common as
g5 and d5 it is what is known as the
shallop defense and that is the move
knight f6 now it is named after a 19th
century german master who was not as
well known as a player as he was as an
opening theoretician this guy edited uh
what was really the only opening
reference work in the 19th century the
handbooked to shock spills so this guy
knew what he was talking about he did a
lot of opening analysis and he came up
with the idea of developing the knight
walking right into the move e5 which
seems to play into white's hands and
whites what's more
the follow-up here is to plant the
knight on h5
if you know nothing about this system it
may seem like black is just stumbling
around and you know the white's going to
win this game in five moves but i invite
you to give this system a chance i will
explain exactly why we do this and why
the system uh is actually
uh incredibly strong both objectively
and practically i think it essentially
takes all of the fun out of the king's
gambit for white white doesn't get an
attack in any line and uh it's practical
in the sense that even if you forget a
specific move but you remember the
general ideas you can still get a very
good position but before we delve into
the main line let's invest a little bit
of time into uh refuting the
alternatives to knight f3 none of which
are particularly good but all of which
you still have to know
and we'll start with the move d4 as i
mentioned black gives a check on h4 and
the best continuation here is to
immediately strike at the center with d5
you sacrifice a pawn but you get this
bishop out really fast and no this
doesn't win white's queen due to knight
f3 but now you aim for very rapid
development and you're basically going
to try to checkmate this king on e2 you
go knight d7 notice that black is
actually the one sacrificing a pawn
and if white takes it there's many many
good moves you can simply castle queen
side here uh but what i came up with is
bishop takes f3 check you you can't take
with a pawn you drop a bishop you have
to take with the king now we avoid the
immediate queen h5 because of g4 we
start with bishop d6 okay well what if
fight takes now we don't take back we
now we give a check on h5 white has to
play g4 now the queen travels and takes
the pawn on d5 and after king f2 the
only thing to remember is not to take
this rook this would be quite bad
because after queenie two check black is
the one who's king gets really exposed
the queen could get trapped here this is
no fun uh so instead you simply play
queen takes d6
and white is virtually lost here because
this king is never going to find a safe
square right it's permanently weak and
as soon as black castles queen side and
gets this night out there will be hell
to pay
so there isn't much to know here other
than the fact that you just castle you
get your night out you can also throw in
the move c5 to open up the center this
line is fairly forced
so d4
queen h4 check and d5 is really really
good for black
there are a couple of slightly more
reputable alternatives here to knight f3
and one of them is knight c3 i think
this is a a variation of the vienna game
which uh the first world champion
wilhelm steinitz was known as kind of an
expert in this line he won a lot of
games here
and white's point after queen h4 king e2
is that he's going to go knight f3 he's
going to chase the queen away then
white's going to go d4 and eventually
the king can kind of castle by hand it
can go to f2 and people in the 1800s
really didn't know how to meet this
steinitz won so many games by doing just
that but i came up with a really cool
and really rare move you actually play
d5 anyway here
now you might look at this and say well
that looks like madness right now i can
take this pawn with a knight that seems
completely unreasonable
uh if if white takes with a pawn here
then you do much the same thing that you
do in the d4 line you go in bishop g4
bishop d6 get this knight out and you
castle but what about knight takes d5
and things get even crazier here you go
bishop g4 check forcing knight f3 and
now you simply ignore the threat on the
c7 pawn you go knight out to c6
what night out to c6 what about knight
take c7 check well we'll get to that in
a second
basically you're threatening knight d4
check so if white goes d4
then you are simply winning after
castles
bishop takes f4 and now knight after f6
and
this position kind of is an illusion it
may seem like white's doing well white's
got all the trappings of a good position
center
you know good development but because
this king is in such trouble all of this
evaporates instantly and white's
position collapses here there's no way
to keep the knight on d5 and if white
takes on f6 you don't even have to take
back you can play play knight takes d4
check
and uh white loses all of his pieces
you're going to take on f3 and win the
queen and then you're going to recapture
the knight this is absolutely terrible
for white so white kind of has to go for
knight takes c7 shack
now we move the king aside after knight
takes a8 we don't give a check on d4 the
king actually escapes through d3 no we
play 95
this probably still looks crazy to you
but when i point out what black is
threatening maybe you can pause the
video and figure that out yourself i
think this idea will start to make a lot
of sense
now let's take a neutral move for white
let's say white plays d4 the point here
is that white black takes on f3 and then
we take again after king takes f3 queen
h5 check we win white's queen there's no
longer a g pawn with which to cover that
check
after we take the queen white's position
is
completely lost because this knight on
eight is also going to be trapped and
the king is still wide open so that's
the main idea and if you look at this
carefully you'll see that white
virtually has no way to stop this white
can play h3 that doesn't help much you
just drop the bishop back one of the
only ideas here is to play rook g1
and if black repeats that process then
the rook's going to cover the check on
g4 but the move h3 creates a huge
weakness on g3 so we go queen g3 and now
we're threatening knight takes f3 and
that is totally unstoppable
so h3 doesn't work
well what does work by the way if white
goes roku one immediately then you can
take this pawn on h2 and now white can't
defend this rook on g1 bishop takes f3
also now is a threat because of the pin
so the only way to take this thing out
of the double uh sacrifice on f3 is
queen e1
offering the queen trade
now we still take on f3 here and if g
takes f3 we we still win the queen
because the king is separated from the
queen
and one very important detail after king
takes f3 queen takes e1 always be
careful and always make sure to check
that white doesn't have a discover check
against black's king but that's why it's
so important that the king is on a dark
square if the king was still on e8 after
bishop b5 track white would win the
queen back and none of this would work
so just an important detail here so in
this position white has to take the
queen
and this position has occurred about 15
times and even richard report who's a
super grandmaster played this with white
in a classical game
not a single person figured out what
black should do here most people went
directly for this knight with king c8
and king b8 but the best move here is to
start with g5 this is kind of a
prophylactic move you're creating a pawn
chain and you're making sure that white
can't use this bishop on c1
uh as a kind of helicopter evacuating
the knight through c7 so you play g5
uh generally white probably will play d3
here if i play as d4
you don't have to rush to win this night
this knight's not going anywhere and
here you can start by playing knight f6
and targeting white's e4 pawn which
incidentally he can't really defend
because g2 is going to fall
and if d3 now the time has come king c8
king b8 and bishop c3 no it does not win
the rook because you have f6 the the one
sample line that i analyzed here and you
don't really have to remember this but
just for the sake of completeness so
fico's e5 this move makes a lot of noise
but black can meet this with knight h6 e
takes f6 and bishop d6 the point is to
get those king side pieces out as fast
as possible so that f7 doesn't trap the
rook the rook moves to c8
not to f8 because of bishop g7 that's a
fork after rook c8 we pick up the pawn
on f7 then we pick up the knight in in
any order and then we not only have two
pieces for the rook which is already
overwhelming but just look at how
dominant our minor pieces are white
simply cannot move here this is winning
for black and this line is quite forcing
so i would spend a little bit of time
and memorize this entire sequence maybe
up until king c8 because it's not
unlikely that somebody is going to try
it and uh you're gonna look like a real
pro when you play the move d5 anyway
you're gonna make your opponent think
that you've blundered and it was just a
bad pre-move but no it's all part of the
game
okay so knight c3 meets with queen h4
check and d5 perhaps the most reputable
alternative to knight f3 is bishop c4
and this is also the only move against
which you do not give a check on h4 very
important detail the reason for that is
that queen h4 check isn't as strong
because the white king now has the f1
square and
as you can see even looking at this for
just a couple of moments the king on f1
is a lot safer than it is on e2 so it's
not worth putting the screen on h4 here
because white's going to attack it with
tempo and moves like d5 just don't come
with the same pizzazz because bishop g4
is not as strong
so what we do here is we simply develop
our knight knight c6 now if white goes
d4
now we give a check on h4 and then we
play d6 what's the difference the
difference is that after knight f3 we
can now bring our bishop to g4 anyway we
can pin the knight to the queen this
essentially forces a queen trade and
this move d4 actually compromises
white's center we're attacking d4 we're
attacking c2 and we're already up a pawn
so black just has a much better end game
here
so this is no good
and the main line here is knight f3 to
which you respond g5 now this is not the
same as going g5 straight away the
position of the bishop on c4 uh is is
actually not great and what we're going
to do here is we're going to fianchetto
our bishop
we're probably going to go h6 to support
the g5 pawn and this g8 knight is going
to come out to e7 this is a very solid
setup black is going to be up upon for
no compensation
so generally white either castles here
goes d4 it probably transposes into each
other castles you play bishop g7
um and if white plays d4 you also play
bishop g7 you're never really afraid of
d5
because you have this very nice e5
square
and this is going to be a recurring
pattern so this line tends to transpose
after white castles or goes c3 so let's
look at it in this move order after you
castle uh after white castles you play
bishop g7 d4 is met with d6 and i was
mostly using the leech s
player database to look up which moves
were most common online and in this
position the vast majority of people
tend to play c3 in order to buttress the
the d4 pawn so here we respond with h6
and
once again most people play queen b3 if
i play queen a4 you can easily parry
that with bishop d7
and uh if white plays queen b3 then
there's a move which has almost never
been played it's not queen e7 we don't
want to obstruct the development of the
knight we want to play queen d7 first of
all we're leaving the e7 square vacated
and second of all we are preparing the
move knight to a5 which would completely
take the teeth out of whatever
compensation white claims to have
because it would lead to a very
desirable trade there's not much why i
can do about it white plays bishop b5
then you can simply play a6
uh i really didn't find anything
resembling a satisfactory move for white
here if the bishop moves back then you
can go either knight f6 or knight g7
then you castle and you've got a
phenomenal position i mean this pawn
chain
is really really cool it prevents the
bishop from coming out it's essentially
unassailable if whatever plays h4
this is not dangerous for many reasons
one of which is that you can just uh get
this queen into g4 and white's king is
the one
that uh you know that has to say its
prayers so
this line is completely innocuous black
has a pawn up for no compensation the
one important thing to remember is that
after bishop c4 you don't play queen h4
check whereas after all other knight
non-knight f3 moves you do now it goes
without saying that after knight of
three don't play queen h4 check i hope
you can see why well now we get to the
fun part now we get to the main line the
move once again is knight f6 the shallop
variation or the shallop defense as it
is formally known
now right away we pose white with a
dilemma okay i can go e5 which my guess
i think if i remember correctly is more
popular in the database
but white doesn't have to go e5 and he
can also defend the pawn with the knight
amazingly the third most popular move
among online games with i think over 15
000 is bishop c4
and and this simply blunders upon i
think this is probably the product of a
bad pre-move maybe most of those games
were bullet games but it's important to
understand that you can take this pawn
you can and you should queenie ii is
totally innocuous on account of queen e7
and the best that white can do is win
one of the pawns back where i can go d3
knight f6 and bishop takes f4 but what's
gonna happen is that you trade queens
and then you build up a nice queen side
pawn wedge with d5 and c6 black is
simply a pawn up in the end game this is
the worst outcome for king's gambit
player having to suffer upon down for no
compensation this bishop is also out of
commission so queen e2 you play queen e7
if we return to this moment
white can also play d3 and bishop takes
f4 but you do the same thing you play d5
and then c6 and
you're chilling and if white castles
then once again you go d5 bishop b3
and now you can get the light squared
bishop out to e6 just supporting the
center one cool detail is that if white
goes d3 here you can actually keep this
extra pawn we go bishop c5 check
forcing d4 otherwise white gets forked
and then the bishop drops back to d6 so
here white doesn't even win back the
second pawn this is virtually resignable
you can go g5 or you can just complete
your development by castling and getting
this night out to c6 or d7 so bishop c4
really is a terrible move
and the last thing i'll say the move d3
has been sometimes played here
the easiest way to respond to this is
just d5
and this is really really crappy for
white after bishop takes f4 the one
thing i will add is that the computer
doesn't love the idea of taking on e4
for complicated reasons so here the best
move is just to develop your knight to
c6
and if white goes e5
once again you go in at h5 and you do
not let white play d4 you shove that
pawn in yourself and this is really
really bad for white this pawn on e5 is
weak your next move can be either bishop
b4 or bishop g4 this is extremely
uncommon and unlikely to happen but just
once again for the sake of completeness
d3 is met with d5 and if white goes e5
here then you play knight h5 and you
basically have the main line down a
tempo for white because there's nothing
better than going d4 so there's no sense
in analyzing this
and now we get to the first of the two
main moves i'd like to start with knight
c3
so here we strike at the center with d5
okay this poses yet another decision in
front of y y can take on d5 or y can
push e5 and the one clarification that i
want to make straight away
is that if you consider the line e5
knight h5 d4
you might look at this and say wait a
minute isn't this the exact same thing
as e5 knight h5 d4 in this position the
answer to that is no because in this
position my move and i'll explain this
is going to be d6 not d5 the point is
that if we go d5 i really didn't like
the position after white's move c4
and if you compare this after knight h
after a knight c3 d5 e5 knight h5 if
white plays d4 there is no longer the
possibility of undermining white's black
center with c4 and so this line is
really really good for black just a
little clarification uh so that you
don't get too confused but before we
look at this i'd like to look at e takes
d5 very popular line knight takes d5 and
now the vast majority of people take
again
if white goes bishop c4 a very common
idea you drop oh no you don't drop the
knight away sorry you play queen e7
check
very nasty little move white
has to go king f1 queen e2 leads to a
pawn down end game so for instance here
you can go knight c3 and then queen
takes c2 and no white does not win this
pawn back because the bishop defends it
very nicely so all of these end games
are really bad for white
uh so so king f1 is is virtually forced
uh king f2 loses a piece to queen c5
check we will see this kind of fork
again very soon
and so after king f1 now you drop the
knight back to b6 with tempo and here
you develop your pieces knight c6 after
d4 i want to make the first kind of
general observation which hopefully will
help you uh understand the ideas of this
line so that you have a fail-safe
mechanism in case you forget the moves
so in the shallow defense
generally black castle's queen side
generally black as king side that is but
in some of these variations particularly
when white's king position is
compromised black switches gears and
says okay i'm going to give up this f4
pawn i'm gonna go for quick queen side
castling in order to uh create a very
rapid fire attack on white skin you're
gonna see this a couple of times and
this is one example bishop g4 yes you
give up this pawn but after castling
queen side you can hopefully see how
dangerous this is for white you're
threatening knight takes d4 because of
the pin if white pushes d5 you go knight
a5 white's position here totally
collapses you're threatening to take the
bishop and isolate this pawn
uh you're threatening to reposition the
queen to f6 this is just such a fun
position to play for black and uh
material is equal which is the best part
so this is not impressive and for that
reason everybody who knows what they're
doing plays knight takes d5 queen takes
d5 and now d4
and now a very important thing to
remember you play bishop e7 here not
bishop d6 well what's the point bishop
takes f4 ridiculously common right
thousands of games loses the bishop i
love these kinds of moves which are good
in and of themselves they also set a
trap so remember this you're gonna i
guarantee you're gonna win some games in
it i'd like to hear that in the youtube
comments when you win your first game by
uh winning this bishop and hopefully
converting the advantage
so why has a couple of alternatives
and this is an important position to to
understand first of all there's the move
c4 attacking the queen
and here we drop our queen back to d6 so
that it defends ff4 and if white keeps
attacking the queen the queen has a
great parking spot on f6
okay so here we're going to castle and
go knight c6 so most people go queen d2
and this is the second instance where we
deliberately give up the give up up the
f4 pawn in order to go for quick
development the move g5 here is totally
fine and black is better but i didn't
love g5 h4 so my recommendation is
knight c6 queen takes f4 and bishop e6
notice that apart from the possibility
of castling queenside white also has
these very weak pawns this bishop is
going to park itself on d5 really an
amazing outpost white is going to
experience a lot of problems with his
center
queen takes c7 walks into knight takes
d4 with pretty devastating consequences
whereas after bishop b5 bishop d5 once
again white can't really take this pawn
because you take twice on f3 and the
king is toast queen e4 bishop h4 there's
going to be mate and there's going to be
gnashing of teeth as my
10th grade math teacher used to say
you're just going to win all of white's
pawns
together with a strong attack and if
white does neither of those things then
you're going to castle queenside on the
next move and quite possibly you're
going to take on f3 and take on d4 so
you might even win a pawn anyway but
from a positional standpoint black has a
great position due to this outpost on d5
and white's weak center
so this is not an impressive line
and by the way if white doesn't go c5
then you take the opportunity to get
this knight out and as i've said before
d5 is almost always met with knight e5
pawn up no compensation not much to talk
about here so c4 is kind of an
old-school move and it's not very good
in recent times more people have been
going bishop d3 but this also fails to
equalize and here we do go g5
and if white castles
we continue developing naturally bishop
g4
now the main line continues c3 defending
the pawn we'll just go knight c6 queen
c2 and we castle queen side once again
uh we reap all of the benefits of the
position here we're still up upon and we
manage to castle now we looked at this
position a little bit and you have to be
precise
uh generally white goes bishop before
attacking the queen and there's a really
cool trap here that i'm just gonna
mention uh because it's cool it's not
crucial to the video
queen d6 looks more natural to me than
queen d7 but here white has a beautiful
tactic and i kind of invite you to pause
the video and take a shot at it so the
tactic comes out of nowhere it's knight
takes g5
um i was analyzing the engine and i
thought what has the engine gone crazy
do i need to clean my computer after
bishop takes g5 no why does bishop f5
check
it forces the bishop trade after queen
takes f5 white picks up the bishop and
black's will kingside structure is now
in shambles
so
most people will probably not see this
in a game but the best move here is
queen d7 and this hinges on a very
important detail it looks like d5 is
very scary if you move the knight away
then you run into 95 but black counter
strikes with f5
dc bc
and first of all the bishop is trapped
the only way to extricate it is to go
knight e5
now the queen moves up to e6 and after
knight takes g4 which piece do we take
well we don't take the knight that loses
the queen we take the bishop and just
look at black's pawn army here this is
almost winning for black white has to
move the knight back you go e3
you're going to bring the rook into e8
white it's totally paralyzed and uh this
is really really fun for
for black and i'll take this opportunity
to say that if at any point moment
you're not satisfied with where i stop
or you might be looking at the video
saying you know daniel mentions this you
know but he doesn't mention this move or
that move i tried to be thorough but i
can't cover everything remember you can
call up an analysis board on chess.com
turn the engine on and join me in uh
analyzing this opening that's a crucial
part that's an integral part of
developing an opening repertoire because
you have a very unique perspective on
which moves are annoying to you and
which moves you would like to know the
response against and when you play a
blitz game in this variation if your
opponent follows a line that i didn't
mention
you want to add that to your file you
want to analyze that and that is a
totally normal process that's how you
enrich your opening knowledge so
this position for instance if you're
uncertain about why black is winning or
why black is better you can you know get
onto an analysis board and just make a
couple of couple more moves
okay so this is an important line
um and to summarize here if white goes
c4
then you drop the queen back to d6 and
if white goes bishop d3 then you defend
the pawn on f4
there are a couple of other alternatives
here let me check my
master file to see what i what i have
here so d5 takes takes
yeah i think that's basically it's uh
bishop e2 you also play g5 this doesn't
really substantively change anything and
that's about it so this line although it
was popular a couple of years ago it
doesn't even come close to equalizing
and now we can look at e5 in this
position remember this is different from
e5 here so keep those lines separate in
your mind knight c3 d5 and e5 so we go
knight h5
and this is the first time that the
knight has landed on h5 so let me talk a
little bit about
uh the rationale behind this entire
setup
now the devil's advocate may say okay
what i don't get is first of all you're
giving white a big center after d4 and
second of all isn't this knight going to
be trapped aren't we going to have
constant problems with discoveries and
this just looks impractical
well wrong on both points because first
of all white driving these pawns further
into the center doesn't mean anything
black can work around these pawns and
very often black can make the move f6 to
undermine white's center so in the
king's gambit white actually doesn't
want to push these pawns out too early
to overextend himself as for the knight
being trapped it's not trapped for two
reasons most of the time we will go g5
and the knight will have an escape hatch
through g7 and later on to e6 or or f5
which is a phenomenal square
in certain positions you can simply play
the move g6 not only does that defend
the knight but that also creates in the
case of an emergency um leave your
possessions in the airplane case of an
emergency we still have the g7 square
for the night so this is an illusion and
at no point can white really move this
knight away from f3 because of the
deadly possibility of queen h4 check
now in this position we continue our
development with knight c6
i looked at a couple of moves here uh
bishop e2 is possible and now you go g5
uh this seems to walk into a tactic but
if you just look one step further this
is another case
where you give up the pawn in order to
get quick development and castle
queenside once again the reason we do
that is because white's king is now very
very compromised now the line i looked
at here is bishop f3
if queen f3 then you can take the pawn
on d4 so don't forget that pawn is weak
and if bishop f3 we blast open the
center f6
knight takes d5 castles and after c4f
takes c5 once again white's position is
on the verge of collapse and the king is
is going to be toast in in the long run
so uh bishop b2 you respond with g5 and
if bishop b5 first we go a6 to force the
bishop to make a decision
uh if bishop a4 once again we can start
with bishop e6 and then we go g5
phenomenal position for black later we
can go knight g7 and knight f5 and i'll
talk more about these positions a little
bit later uh and if white plays bishop
takes c6 we play b takes c6 we're not
worried about this pawn structure being
slightly damaged in fact the d5 pawn is
now even better supported than before
there goes g5 and if knight e1 there
goes the knight to g7 h4 can always be
met with h6 you're never worried about
that and uh the one game continued g3 fg
and white is look just look at this king
we're up two pawns knight's coming to f5
uh you know i would pause the video in
one of these positions just you know
make sure that you understand why these
positions are so overwhelming so my
suggestion would be
maybe take a look at this position
and just fully understand or sorry
bishop e2 g5 fully understand all of the
ideas what i mentioned about knight g7
uh and you can always slow down and take
the higher level view the only other
move here that i looked at here is
bishop d3 and once again you go g5
if castles then you can push the spawn
all the way down to g4 because the
bishop has intercepted the queen's
control over d4
and uh if if knight d1 then knight takes
d4 is absolutely absolutely crushing
uh so i looked at h4 here but now we go
g4 knight g5 and once again we can
simply take the pawn on d4 now we're two
pawns up and we've kept all of the
advantages of the position so
none of these moves are dangerous uh and
so knight c6 i think simply refutes uh
this this sub variation i i didn't see
anything
remotely appealing that that white could
do and that finally brings us to the
main move e5 e5 knight h5 and virtually
everybody is going to play d4 now the
interesting thing is that john shaw who
is a scottish grandmaster
and a noted opening expert he wrote a
very good book on the kings game but i
think a couple of years ago
and i consulted that book to see what he
recommends against this line shaw
recommends a rare move bishop e2 in this
position essentially trying to target
this knight as quickly as possible
and the other person that i want to
credit is a national master named joseph
truelsen joseph created an excellent
chessable course uh on playing against
the king's gamut where he recommends the
shallop
now i didn't consult his chestable
course too much
but i looked at some of his
recommendations his analysis is
excellent i highly recommend it
as a supplement to this video i'll link
it in the description below and i'd like
to credit joseph uh for coming up with
an excellent recommendation against
shaw's move which shaw himself does not
consider once again we go knight c6
but the the crux of this
is that after castles if white goes d4
then we go with the immediate d6 this is
going to transpose because in this
position white has nothing better to do
than to castle so if castles
here we go d6
white kind of has to go d4 if e takes d6
in any such position it's it's bad
because our knight now has an easy
retreat back to f6 so after d4
we go g6 i mention this move sometimes
we go g5 sometimes we go g6 now you
might ask well why not g5 the reason g5
is bad here consists in the move d5 this
is kind of shaw's point
knight takes c5 obviously loses a piece
and white's pawns really can cause some
damage if they get to e6
so here we go g6
and uh i think this takes the sting out
of this line he takes
he takes d6 excuse me
take a sip of coffee
now i feel like i got madder drink my
water pause the video now
so if if white doesn't take then then
you fianchetto the bishop
he takes d6 he takes d6 and we're just
better uh yet again d5 is met with
knight e5
and there's a forcing line here white
can win the pawn back take stakes and
takes but uh we can throw in a check
and when the smoke clears we shift our
queen to g6 and we just have this
monster pawn chain on the on the king
side the bishop's coming out to f5 and
in the event of a queen trade i mean
hopefully you can see that this position
is absolutely overwhelming
for black so this is not dangerous and
instead of knight c3 if black white
takes immediately then we take with the
bishop
and after knight c3
uh we can castle
charleston stops his analysis here i
found them of knight e5 interesting
attempt to muddy the waters but now we
drop our knight back to g7 here's the
idea in action and although white can
win the pawn back by taking on c6 and
taking on f4 his uh relief is
short-lived our knight travels to e6 and
causes
a lot of problems bishop d6 queen d6 and
white cannot defend this pawn and if
white tries to be cheeky with bishop e5
then we we grab it and we go
queen g5 and once again the pawn cannot
be defended this is probably white's
best line objectively but at the end of
it he's down upon he's clearly worse and
this would require white to play
accurately for for 14 moves so not a
great outcome and so bishop e2 thank you
to joseph for finding the move knight c6
and now we get to the move which you're
going to see a lot more frequently and
that is d4
okay so i vacillated for a while on d5
versus d6 scrolls and recommends d5 but
ultimately i was not able to find
anything too satisfactory after c4 and
that is why i settled on d6
i also like this move because it
virtually forces white to find and only
move every other move and white is in
huge trouble the only move
that gives white a tenable position is
queen e2 which is virtually never played
in online games in over-the-board chess
among grandmasters yes gm's know to play
queen e2 but most people online make one
of two moves and both of them are really
bad
most people play bishop c4
this walks right into what we want to do
now we go d5 and everything changes
after bishop d3 g5 we have one at tempo
so the move c4
is totally not dangerous so for instance
after castle's knight c6 if white might
generally go c3 if i go to c4 we capture
on c4 now we make a really cool move
rook g8
now you might look at this and say whoa
whoa what about d5 this looks scary it's
actually not we go g4 counter-striking
on the king side and although this may
look a little chaotic white is actually
just completely lost here and i'm gonna
block your socks off with a cool line in
just a second but here if fight plays d
takes c6
trade queens take on f3
don't forget the black is already a pawn
up and now the attack against white's
king has grown totally devastating
now if white goes c3 in this position
then
we develop our bishop and one cool line
that i considered was b4
trying to get something going on the
queen side g4
forcing the knight back and now a5
undermining the queen side but what's
the idea what does black do after b5
good spot to pause the video and try to
figure it out there is a beautiful idea
here
take on e5
after d takes e5 the idea of going a5
has been revealed we now have access to
the c5 square and now we sack another
piece on g3 and hopefully you see where
this is going this is a common mating
pattern our bishop controls g1 there's
nothing white can put on this diagonal
that can't be captured and queen h5 or
h6 checkmate is totally
unstoppable it is inevitable white loses
so just one of many really really cool
lines that i think show how fun this uh
variation is to play that knight on h5
has some teeth it doesn't just passively
sit there defending f4 in certain
situations it can sacrifice itself on g3
and so
uh it turns out that this bishop c4 move
is is just bad we just go d5 d5 followed
by g5
and then we develop our pieces knight to
c6 bishop to e6 other bishop to e7 and
at any moment we can drop our knight
back to g7
okay so what about e takes d6 well as
i've already mentioned this walks right
into black's hands bishop takes d6
and now we develop normally castles
castles bishop g4 and bishop g4 is
always a good move here because after h3
we don't have to take the knight we drop
our bishop back and we have induced h3
creating a massive weakness on g3 uh
where we can now ensconce our knight so
black is a pawn up and
as my coach used to say black is the
extra pawn and e has the compensation so
we're we're doing great here
and the only other move that i saw
played with any regularity online is
knight c3 but this ignores the idea of
d6 we play d takes e5 and white is in a
tough spot because knight takes c5 loses
to queen h4 check
d takes c5 allows the queen trade which
is obviously really good for black the
only
uh tenable move is queen e2 but now we
get our bishop to g4
and after queen takes e5 check we play
bishop e7
and there's this one detail that i would
advise that you memorize after knight t5
you have to know the move knight c6
and its idea is not hard to understand
after knight takes c7 king f8 there is
no way for the queen to keep protecting
the knight the queen has to drop back
and white loses the knight so no we're
not blundering a fork here uh we're just
seeing one step ahead so this is good
for black
and uh knight c3 just d takes e5
and so that leads me to
what i would really call the only
serious move in this position and that
is queen e2
but again i think you're unlikely to
face it i think you're more likely to
face bishop c4 or bishop e2 and as a
sneak preview
uh on the opening videos
that i will be making i'll be making a
series of videos very soon where i
actually recruit people from my twitch
community and my supporters to play a
series of games with me in the same
opening so i ask them to basically play
the kings indian in ten consecutive
games and then i'll put out a video
where i'm actually putting uh this
theoretical information to practice and
hopefully that'll give you a slightly
different perspective and hopefully
it'll help solidify not only the theory
but also the general ideas because i'm
sure that i'll be facing lines that i
haven't covered
okay so let's get to queenie two
now we take on e5
and once again queen takes e5 anytime we
can trade queens like this we should and
black is better bishop e2 we don't have
to rush with queen takes e5 first we
develop our bishop to g4
and uh if bishop takes f4 another
example
of a situation where we sacrifice back
the pawn but we have a huge initiative
if the bishop drops back then
knight comes into b4
it drops back down to d5 and what i want
you to notice here is that the lack of
the f dupont really hurts white in more
than one way it doesn't just weaken the
king it also doesn't allow the bishop on
e3 to be anchored now white has to move
the bishop back and the knight comes
into f4 so white's position is really
discombobulated as a result of the f
pawn not being there
meanwhile if bishop takes c7 then we
chase that bishop and the bishop
literally has nowhere to go bishop g3 we
grab we grab and we grab and we're gonna
grab on c2 with uh totally devastating
effect so queen takes e5 we cover with
the queen the one important thing here
is not to take the queen straight away
because then white takes back with the
knight and attacks then on h5 here we
got to be patient and get your bishop
out to g4
um i guess so i can play h3 here which i
didn't analyze but now you can grab the
queen because obviously if knight takes
e5 you're gonna fork him in the end and
if d takes e5 now we can drop the bishop
back and once again knight g3 is going
to be very very strong
so that really only leaves us with
knight takes e5 d takes c5 bishop g4
just looks terrible for white h3 there's
always knight g3
after queen takes e5
sorry after knight takes e5
as as you might imagine
you give a check on h4
okay why is it one moment
i guess the the gods don't want me to
complete this video okay i think we're
good night takes e5
queen h4 it kept reverting back to that
position maybe uh somebody hacked this
analysis board he's like daniel you
haven't explained that well enough so
queen h4 check
at first sight this just looks great for
for black right because as we've already
established g3
is almost never possible in these
positions and so if white has to move
the king away well well that's no good
right we can just play bishop b7 and
you know then we castle and white's
position is terrible
uh but it turns out that white can play
g3 here
and the point is that after f takes g3
white uses the discovery and wins
black's queen before we have a chance uh
to win white's rook white goes knight g6
check
no problem you might say
don't we have the move knight takes g3
and we do you do play knight takes g3
and now no discovery works because the
queen is attacked so white has to play
hg3 and we play queen takes h1 now i
would say that this is the only
variation in this entire line which one
could refer to as messy and that doesn't
mean it's bad and that doesn't mean you
can't tackle it i would just suggest
that you spend you know
maybe an hour reviewing this segment of
the video and really making sure that
you understand every move that is played
from this point on and that you
basically have it memorized this is
really only one of two lines that i
think you should memorize
now first things first thing to get out
of the way
why does the move knight g6 check there
should be six knight takes a trade and
yes white is a piece up but he's also
completely lost because of white's total
lack of development and also the fact
that the knight on h8 is stranded and
the fact that black has a bunch of extra
pawns on the king side
so
here we play knight c6 then we take on
g3
and you know fight offers a queen trade
we decline it and our next couple of
moves are going to be castle's queenside
then we're going to get the bishop out
not only are we going to win the night
back but white's king is absolutely
devastated so this is another good
position to dig around in you can set
this up and just make a couple of moves
and convince yourself that this is
completely and totally winning for black
by the way d5 walks into bishop takes d5
and that is why we put the queen on h4
we're gonna promote on the next move and
make a second queen
okay
so instead of knight g6 check white has
to be patient and the only move is
bishop takes f4
now we make another move which might
seem puzzling we play bishop d6 you just
have to remember that white doesn't
actually have any dangerous discoveries
once again if knight g6 check we respond
in exactly the same way bishop b6 knight
takes h8 and the same principle we take
on f4 we go knight c6 we castle
and we win the knight back and then
we're gonna be up a pawn and we're gonna
have a long-term attack on white's uh
white's king so this is really really
bad
after knight d2 the one thing i'd throw
in is that white is ready to castle
queenside so you can throw in a check on
h4
and um
you can trade queens take on h8 and this
should be winning for black up a pawn
and you have an outside passer
so once again knight g6 track is not
dangerous here and so uh the people who
know what they're doing uh are going to
go knight c3 but for context this has
only occurred in over-the-board chess
twice
uh and uh one of those games was
napomnishi against ferruja from a recent
tournament so nepo is one of the only
top grandmasters who still likes to play
the king's gambit on occasion and yes he
knew what to do here but uh even if
white plays perfectly as you'll see he's
gonna have a worse end game
finally we castle that's why we played
bishop d6 well white has nothing to do
but to castle himself
now the threat here that we have to deal
with is bishop g2 so let's if we make a
random move we lose our queen bishop g2
queen h2 rook h1
and black's next move is aimed against
bishop g2 we go bishop h3 we beat white
to the punch
all right so bishop g2 doesn't work
anymore
and
our point is that we're gonna get our
knight out to c6 and we're just gonna be
up in exchange we're gonna consolidate
and in this position the only move that
enables white to stay in the game is
knight takes f7 again a move that
somebody really has to know
uh i looked at this online and a couple
of people so if white takes on h3 and
then plays queen e4 this is a tricky
attempt because rook h1 is a thread and
then you're gonna have problems with h7
so here uh you bring the queen back to
e6 and this is a paper tiger you just go
knight d7 and black has consolidated his
extra exchange
a couple of people have gone knight e4
which is a good looking move right
centralizing the knight doesn't do
anything we just go knight d7 a lot of
pieces that are hanging but in reality
uh all of this favors black if if uh
well if g4 you go knight out to f6
uh forcing the trade and white's
position collapses here
just note that this construction is
totally self-sufficient there's no way
for right to put pressure on either of
these pieces and at the right moment you
can take on f1 and hit the queen and
then bring your queen back that's really
the point and if knight g5
here's a case in point you take on e5
then you take on f1 and then you bring
your queen back to c6 and you're
completely winning we're up in exchange
and a pawn
so
none of the moves other than knight
takes f7 are dangerous the point of
knight takes f7 is to expose black's
king so that you can later get this
bishop out with check
what we do here is we take on f4 now we
do not take on f7 never play this move
because you're gonna get checkmated and
do not take with the king because you
might not get checkmated but you're
definitely going to lose your queen and
probably even more than that instead you
play the very calm move knight d7
getting your knight out if white moves
the knight away then you know the drill
bishop takes f1
rook takes f1 queen c6 there's no check
on c4 you're just going to play h6 and
rookie 8 and we're completely in charge
and up in exchange so queen c4 is the
only only move
now we take on f7 and the point of this
is revealed white takes on f7 and then
plays bishop c4 check and the smoke is
cleared white is going to win the queen
back but guess what we drop our bishop
back to e6
white can't take immediately because he
loses the bishop but after bishop takes
c6 rook takes c1 and knight f6
okay white has found 20 computer moves
you applaud you take your hat off and
guess what black is still better black
has a clear advantage in the end game
because we are the ones with the past
h-pawn and white is the one with uh
incredibly weak pawns particularly the
one on f4 which is easy to attack so i
left the computer running here for a
while the engine tends to say that white
can hold the draw with accurate play but
i think this is a pretty darn positive
outcome particularly because white has
found all these moves and for the king's
gambit player to play a worse end game
is probably you know worse than eating
dirt for the rest of their lives so so
just remember this line let's go through
that one more time
um if queen e2 you play d takes e5 you
give this check now first pitfall don't
take with a pawn take with a knight and
really the moment where i think a lot of
people might be confused is here you
don't
there's a temptation to block the queen
but you don't do that you go bishop d6
and it's important to understand why
it's not dangerous to lose that rook on
h8 if white keeps developing you castle
and the third thing to remember is not
to allow bishop g2 but rather to play
bishop h3 and if somebody knows knight
takes f7 then you take on f4 you make
the calm move knight d7 and you get this
liquidation don't forget to play bishop
b6 here right otherwise white takes on
h1 and sort of skewers the pawn and you
play knight f6 and you're better
so that essentially concludes
uh my presentation of the shallow
defense let's
do a quick overview of what we went
through so after e takes f4 we went
through the alternatives to knight f3 we
looked at knight c3 bishop c4
and and d4 you play queen h4 check
against d4 knight c3 but not against
bishop c4 because the king will have the
f1 square
then we started looking at the actual
shallow defense and i will add some a
detail i forgot to mention
is that the first mention of this move
uh was not by charlotte himself but by
yes rui lopez can you believe it in his
uh i think this was written in i have to
check my source let me see i wrote this
down
rue lopez uh the originator of the
spanish game he was a priest but he also
wrote one of the first chess manuscripts
it was a it was a chess instruction book
i think it was the late 1500s but don't
quote me on that
uh so he made mention of this movie he
analyzed a bunch of openings and rui
lopez seemed to think that knight f6 is
bad
because after e5 knight h5
um if you didn't even consider knight h5
he i think he only considered like
knight e4 and then the knight gets
tossed around
um or no no he did
and he mentioned that after g4 black is
on passant so one of the coolest things
uh that the author mentions this is a
book called the classical era of modern
chess it basically traces the very first
books written about chess and talks
about what they talked about and uh
there's a debate about when on passant
entered common chess rules and this is a
very important piece of evidence so this
line we're talking about is also used by
chess historians as evidence that on
passant existed in the late 1500s
because rue lopez made mention of it g4
would have trapped the knight were it
not for on passant i don't remember
exactly why he thought this was bad but
he didn't like it neither did polario
who was an italian master uh who wrote a
manuscript around the same time as rue
lopez and uh charlotte was only the
third or fourth player to actually play
this in over-the-board chess the first
player to play this was a very imposing
name and i'm sure i'll butcher the
pronunciation count conrad vitshum von
ekstadt
who was the uh heir of a noble family in
germany uh so he was the first person to
to play knight f6 and and he did put the
knight on h5 but shalop really codified
this he analyzed it and so and the the
line bears his name a little piece of
chess trivia there
so knight f6 we looked at the two main
moves knight c3 and e5 if bishop c4 you
can grab the pawn
um after knight c3 we strike at the
center with d5
remember the key detail after e5 knight
h5 d4 we can simply develop because
white doesn't have the move c4
uh we also looked at e takes d5 and then
essentially you cling to this pawn in
most cases and sometimes you castle king
side sometimes if you feel that white's
king is particularly weak you can castle
queen side and finally we looked at the
main line e5 knight h5 d4 now do not
play d5 because it allows uh nasty moves
you follow if you look at joseph trolls
and stressable course i'm sure that he
does some very good work on d5 as well
but the move is d6 the idea is to
quickly undermine white center against
bishop c4 now you play d5 with tempo and
you know the drill knight c6 g5 etc
against almost all other moves you play
d take c5 including the main line queen
e2 you take c5 and
even with best play white ends up
slightly worse
alright ladies and gentlemen that was a
pretty long video let me check how long
it was it was 51 minutes that's about
exactly the same length as the first
time i recorded it
i hope to god that the board
transmission bug did not make another
appearance i'll be
reviewing that right after i click stop
record but if you've made it to this
this far thank you so much and
congratulations it is not easy to sit
through an opening video this long but
again my philosophy of my channel and of
the opening videos is that
i'm offering you this invest an hour and
you will have a repertoire that might
very well last you a lifetime so as
usual please feel free to leave comments
leave questions uh in the comments below
below and i will try to get to as many
of them as i can and finally i have
started a patreon so by popular demand i
do have a patreon now i'm going to link
it in the description i just want to
make it clear zero obligation this is
not meant to pressure anybody and uh you
know
not and none of my content is now going
to be behind a paywall but the only
thing i'm going to offer as part of one
of the tiers is uh some people ask for
pgns i will have a pgn available for uh
for patrons at all tiers so feel free to
check it out i greatly appreciate the
support you guys are all awesome but
please don't feel any obligation uh to
become a patron
or do that i i love everyone equally but
just wanted to put that out there for
your information so the link will be
below well i hope you enjoyed i hope you
now are armed with the tools you need to
kill the king's gambit to crush it with
a k
and i will see you in the next video
thank you so much and goodbye
[Music]